los dos equipos finalistas de este
mundial de Qatar 2022 entrenaron con sus
equipos al completo en la víspera de ese
gran partido este domingo en el estadio
del usai Argentina con 26 jugadores
Francia con sus 24 efectivos disponibles
con la albiceleste destaca el regreso de
Alejandro El papu Gómez quien se había
perdido los dos últimos partidos por un
esguince de tobillo compareció su
seleccionador en la previa de esa sesión
Lionel scaloni quien dijo que ya tiene
definido el equipo pero no sabe Si
jugará con línea de tres o línea de
cuatro en defensa algo que según él no
afecta la manera de jugar de su equipo
con el conjunto europeo con Francia
didier de habló acerca de ese cuadro
viral que ha sacudido a los suyos dijo
que han tenido que adaptarse ante ello
para la sesión de ese sábado regresaron
Rafael bahamiray kingsley los últimos
afectados por ese cuadro viral por esa
gripa que los ha mantenido al margen los
últimos 10 también volvieron Diego
Hernández y ofeliam y que estuvieron
ausentes en la sesión del viernes por
unas molestias físicas a the change de
nuevo se le preguntó por Karim Benzema
el Balón de Oro que seleccionó al
comienzo de ese certamen y no ha podido
estar con leblé se le preguntó sobre si
cree que va a estar en esa final
apoyando a sus compañeros hijo de Sam yo
no soy el encargado de hacer las
invitaciones el sentir compartido de
ambos bandos Eso sí es que este partido
esta final no es un duelo entre Messi y
mbappé afirman que es un duelo mucho más
grande en este partido el que vamos a
ver y que va a definir qué equipo le
pone la tercera estrella a su escudo